la coordination des infirmières en grève
reçu ce soir par le ministre de la santé
sans nouvelles propositions une ultime
tentative pour trouver une issue au
conflit
les socialistes en porte à faux à
l'assemblée nationale le malaise social
dominent les débats le ps démarche du
gouvernement
après le déluge les embarras nîmes gère
l'abondance des secours et les
difficultés de la démonisation maurice
papon nouvelle fois accusé de crimes
contre l'humanité l'ancien ministre s'en
explique dans ce journal
tour de france l'itinéraire 89 vient
d'être dévoilé une couronnera le coureur
le plus complet
voilà monsieur bonsoir
où en est-on dans les hôpitaux en france
oublions un instant les négociations les
mots d'ordre pour aller à la réalité
voici trois semaines maintenant que les
infirmières et les personnels
hospitaliers sont en grève dans leur
ensemble les médecins à commencer par
quelques grands patrons soutiennent leur
mouvement les infirmières ont à coeur de
ne pas compromettre la qualité des soins
mais il est évident que plus le conflit
dure plus le fonctionnement quotidien
des services hospitaliers devient
difficile c'est ce que daniel duigou a
constaté à l'hôtel dieu à paris
une nouvelle journée de grève
aujourd'hui à l'hôtel dieu dans le hall
d'accueil les aides soignants décide de
se mobiliser avec les infirmières les
kinésie et les manipulateurs
radiologiste mail à 100 mètres au même
moment dans le bloc opératoire une
urgence est assuré comme d'ailleurs
l'ont été toutes les urgences depuis le
début du conflit la règle générale c'est
l'entente entre médecins et infirmières
pour sélectionner les malades y assurer
les priorités ainsi cette équipe en
chirurgie elle établit au jour le jour
le tableau des interventions cette
semaine sur la vingtaine d'interventions
programmé quatre vous prenez pas un
risque en reculant un certain nombre
d'interventions
on peut pas le nier c'est pour cela que
la drève et éprouvante pour tout le
monde et nous en sommes tous cons
sial personnel infirmier aussi certains
services fonctionnent donc seulement à
20 % de leurs capacités et c'est
pourquoi la direction commence à
s'inquiéter des conséquences de la grève
sur tous elle devait se poursuivre dans
toute entreprise en arrêt de travail
c'est un coût financier notamment bon il
est clair que c'est pas pratique pour
l'instant puisque l'assistance publique
en activité en forte hausse depuis début
d'année puissent 4% en nombre de malades
soignés par conséquent la grève ne va
pas entamer l'activité globale de
l'assistance publique
l'autre coup c'est le coût social nokia
c'est une entreprise copro une
entreprise de marge que s'il ya une
cohésion interne si les gens se battent
se sont opposés à ce qu'ils croient tout
grève un coût mais le travail des
infirmières nous a répondu le personnel
a aussi un prix il n'est pas nécessaire
de nommer un médiateur pour résoudre
votre conflit c'est ce que le premier
ministre michel rocard a répondu ce soir
à la coordination des infirmières
cette coordination le ministre de la
santé vient de la rencontre et le
dialogue reprend des à quoi va-t-il
aboutir
claude evin apparemment n'a pas de
nouvelles propositions à mettre sur la
table mais c'est en tout cas avec ce
mouvement majoritaire à la base et non
pas avec les syndicats que le contact
est rétabli ou en étant ce soir maryse
mano depuis une heure la coordination
des infirmières poursuit son 5ème tête à
tête avec l'eau des vins faute d'avoir
obtenu un rendez vous à matignon
visage fermé pas de déclarations
personne ne croit ici à la signature
d'un protocole d'accord ce soir car il
ne s'agit pas on le précise bien au
ministère de rouvrir les négociations
les propositions de la semaine dernière
ne bougeront pas d'un pouce 2 milliards
de francs pour les augmentations de
salaires la formation les effectifs de
même il n'y aura pas de médiateur comme
le souhaitait la coordination michel
rocard ne l'a pas jugé utile dans ces
conditions si la coordination a jugé bon
de venir quand même ce soir c'est
qu'elle cherche peut-être une issue
honorable à un conflit qui menace de
s'essouffler
la coordination des infirmières soutenue
par un comité de personnalités réunies
autour du professeur shorten berg
appelle toujours à la manifestation
samedi et la puissante fédération des
mutuelles de france invitera ses
adhérents à y participer
toutes les fédérations de fonctionnaires
cgt comprise on mettre demain leur poids
dans la rue la journée nationale
d'action décidée par les syndicats va
unifier et accentué les mouvements de
grève et de mécontentement qui depuis
quelques temps affecte les transports
les ptt l'enseignement et l'électricité
demain les transports en commun et
l'enseignement seront particulièrement
touchés alors pour vous organiser au
mieux le point avec à l'adouber ski sncf
le trafic tgv sera normale affirme la
direction pour les autres un train sur
deux banlieue parisienne en moyenne 1
train sur 3 ratp 1 métro sur 2 les
lignes les plus touchées seront les
suivantes 2 7 8 et 12 rer situation très
difficile sur la ligne à mais un train
sur deux sur les lignes b et c ptt
préavis de grève pour l'ensemble des
services et des grades 12 grosses
perturbations à prévoir demain éducation
nationale tous les syndicats appellent à
la grève
de nombreuses écoles seront fermées
grève des cours dans les lycées mais
l'accueil sera assuré dans les
établissements restés ouverts
air france tous les long-courriers
seront maintenues mais seuls 70% des
moyen courriers devraient prendre le
départ
renseignements numéros suivants 43 20 11
52 3
terre inter tous les vols seront assurés
affirme une direction plein d'expérience
dans le domaine des grèves
edf coupures de courant prévues pour les
particuliers et les entreprises en
raison d'une baisse de la production dès
6h45 demain l'équipe de télématin sera à
nouveau à pied d'oeuvre à la gare saint
lazare à paris pour mieux conseiller les
habitants de l'agglomération parisienne
sur ceux qui marchaient sur ce qui ne
marche pas au conseil des ministres de
ce matin
les conflits sociaux n'était pas à
l'ordre du jour dès le premier ministre
qui doit obtenir à l'assemblée nationale
le vote du budget et keane à l'assemblée
qu'une majorité relative michel rocard
donc a reçu l'autorisation d'engager
éventuellement sur ce projet la
responsabilité du gouvernement
il pourra donc si besoin est recourir au
fameux 49 terre cet article de la
constitution qui permet au gouvernement
de compter sa majorité est de faire
adopter un texte par le biais d'une
question de confiance à l'assemblée
nationale justement les députés ont
continué ce matin de discuter budget
mais le débat de l'après midi a été bien
sûr largement dominé par les conflits
sociaux
le premier ministre s'est dit prêt à
discuter du fond avec les fonctionnaires
en prenant le temps nécessaire et en
adoptant aussi une approche sectorielle
métier par métier
mais pour les députés socialistes la
conjoncture politique est bien difficile
parce qu'elle lignée début de la saison
des humeurs au palais-bourbon l'automne
s'impose et les socialistes auraient
comme du vague à l'âme
un soupçon de spleen très politique à
cause d'une rentrée sociale qui se fait
entendre jusque sous les fenêtres de
l'assemblée bien sûr le gouvernement
s'affirme bel et bien prêt un large
dialogue mais beaucoup de députés
trouvent le temps un peu long
entre ceux qui poussent les aiguilles et
ceux qui préféreraient se hâter
lentement tout un jeu contre la montre
sur fond de court en numéro
d'équilibrisme concilier solidarité avec
le gouvernement en mettant que
solidarité avec les manifestants
exercice difficile nous sommes à notre
place
nous soutenons le gouvernement mais nous
exprimons
les intérêts des salariés et le
gouvernement devraient être attentifs à
ce que nous lui disons on se rend compte
effectivement que la politique de
rigueur atteint ses limites au sens où
des catégories sociales ont le sentiment
qu'elle n'est pas assez justement
répartis il faut lâcher davantage
je sais pas s'il faut relâcher davantage
mais faut lâcher mieux je crois que
c'est notre rôle
en même temps de soutenir une politique
qui est bonne en même temps de
comprendre des interrogations légitimes
en même temps de discuter avec le
gouvernement pour que cette politique
évolue dans un sens social qui est celui
du gouvernement et que nous souhaitons
monstre qu'il ya deux possibilités ce
qu'on pense qu'un député socialiste ça
doit toujours être derrière son
gouvernement
le doigt sur la couture on pense qu'un
député socialiste ça doit être d'abord
sur le terrain
à écouter les gens et à faire remonter
ce qu'il entend sur le terrain et à
dialoguer appartement avec le
gouvernement sur ce qu'il entend c'est
ce que j'essaye de faire en ce moment la
question qui est posée pour nous ces cas
de bonnes questions et aussi à propos de
bonnes réponses et c'est là qu'il peut y
avoir quelques différences dans
l'appréciation que les que les
parlementaires porte élections
gouvernement à l'écouté de ses troupes
de tout ces trous pierre mauroy le
premier secrétaire est monté en personne
au filet histoire de savoir ce que le
gouvernement était bien faire pour la
fonction publique
réponse du premier ministre je vous ai
compris que les salariés se rassurent la
discussion de fond va s'engager métier
par métier et ce qui vaut pour le
secteur privé vaudra aussi pour le
secteur public
nous voulions nous a dit hier au coup
par coup ce n'est pas exact ce dont il
est question c'est d'agir au cas par cas
ce qui est fort différent parce que tous
ne sont pas comparables ne pas s'aliéner
ses propres députés ne pas décevoir les
salariés tout en respectant les grands
équilibres
la marge est étroite le matin
jean-jacques queyranne le porte-parole
du parti socialiste sera l'invité de
gérard morin aux 4 vérités
la cote de popularité du président de la
république et du premier ministre accuse
le coup des conflits sociaux selon le
sondage que publiera demain paris match
le chef de l'état perd trois points et
garde 60% d'opinions favorables michel
rocard à 53%
perd 4 points et demi globalement les
français sont moins satisfaits de la
manière dont ils sont gouvernés
une personne sur 210 maintenant me
contente grève mise à part comment
améliorer la sécurité des trains en
france la sncf doit publier vendredi le
rapport qui fait suite aux accidents en
série de l'été dernier les
recommandations tiennent en un chiffre
4,1 milliards de francs qu'il faudrait
investir en cinq ans
patrice pollet la sncf veut tout d'abord
simplifier les textes qui réglementent
les procédures d'exploitation des textes
clairs et mieux présenter pour une
meilleure compréhension du travail de
chacun ensuite c'est le système
d'exploitation qui sera amélioré un
exemple l'installation d'un dispositif
de contrôle de vitesse à l'entrée des
gares souterraines de paris-nord et
d'austerlitz de nouveaux butoir à
absorption d'énergie seront mis en place
des goulets d'étranglement seront
supprimés des voies seront doublés le
matériel ferroviaire va évoluer surtout
en banlieue on pourra contrôler la
vitesse des trains grâce à un système de
balises les freins seront plus
performants le système d'alarmé
classique sera complété par un autre
système à base d'interphone enfin le
dernier point concerne l'aspect humain
la sncf souhaite rendre plus efficaces
les agents grâce à la formation continue
le personnel sera associé le plus
possible aux travaux de réflexion sur la
sécurité
la sncf essaie problème ce sera
précisément le thème de ma soir à 22h30
de l'édition spéciale de claude sérillon
où en est-on à nîmes où en est-on quinze
jours après le déluge et les inondations
qui provoquèrent la mort de neuf
personnes et d'énormes dégâts
vous avez été nombreux à manifester
concrètement votre solidarité avec les
sinistrés
rémy roche est allé constater sur place
les difficultés de gérer ces secours est
aussi d'enclencher des indemnisations
nécessaire on a travaillé pour gagner
tout ça
et puis bon ben voila quoi ça par an en
l'espace d'une matinée que rien mais qui
auraient peur que ça se reproduise
muriel et pascal avait emménagé dans ce
rez de chaussée le 2 octobre la veille
de la catastrophe
le 3 ils avaient pratiquement tout perdu
depuis ils sont relogés au dessus dans
ce qu'il faut bien appeler un taudis
qu'ils espèrent rapidement quitter pour
un vrai logement que leur propose la
mairie
en attendant il se débrouille avec
quelques meubles et des appareils
ménagers fournis par les secours et
souvenirs malgré tout ce qu'on s'entend
bien avec les gens disent qu'on a de la
chance et beaucoup de gens la chance
qu'il faisait avait eu ça vous allait
être meublé gratuitement et tout ton
corps de gens qui pensent ça muriel et
parce qu'elle habite le quartier
richelieu le plus pauvre de nîmes est
l'un des plus endommagés
ici au moins 40% des sinistrés n'avaient
pas la moindre assurance centre ville on
s'active parfois jour et nuit dans ces
commerces afin d'effacer au plus vite
les dégâts
en plus des stocks et des machines
détruit ceux qui n'ont pas réouvert en
sont déjà plus de quinze jours de pertes
d'exploitation et les discussions en
cours s'annonce parfois difficiles avec
les experts des assurances
même si les compagnies affirment vouloir
le plus possible faire preuve de
bienveillance à l'ensemble des
organismes d'assurance
ont pris l'initiative de demander à
leurs représentants à leurs experts leur
inspecteur d'avoir une attitude jaillir
d'une présente à une certaine souplesse
en particulier au niveau de l'évaluation
il est bien évident on ne va pas pouvoir
réclamer comme à l'habitude des
justificatifs de tous les biens détruits
puisque par définition le plus souvent
les justificatifs sont partis avec les
miens les biens détruits
la solidarité
près de 50 millions de francs collectés
et jusqu'à 22 mille mètres carrés
d'entrepôts occupés par des dons en
nature venus de partout
un travail que le sun pour ceux qui ont
réceptionné avant de redistribuer tout
ce qui est arrivé
la solidarité c'est l'abondance et c'est
très bien mais ça doit être également la
qualité
tout ce qui nous était donnée n'était
pas redistribuable il a fallu trier
faire vérifier en particulier à paris
ménagers et parfois apporter des
modifications ou arranger le moby dick
ne t'apporte lundi une nouvelle
distribution plus massive commencera
avec le plus possible de matériels neufs
achetés en gros nîmes est en
convalescence mais certains disent que
le plus dur est à venir alors que
l'hiver arrive et que la solidarité
risque de s'émousser
la ville aura bientôt panser ses plaies
mais il faudra du temps pour que les
meurtrissures des sinistrés se
cicatrisent exubérance à paris prudence
à new york
les professionnels de la bourse ont
marqué aujourd'hui de diverses manières
l'anniversaire du crack qui l'automne
dernier branlée toutes les places
financières la bourse de paris a pris
1,32 % aujourd'hui
wall street a maintenu plus
difficilement ses positions on verra
demain matin l'état de tokyo tokyo qui
en un an s'est affirmée comme la
première place financière du monde
claire chazal et véronique auger la
panique à tokyo le 19 octobre dernier
le signal de l'effondrement de toutes
les bourses du monde est donné l'indicé
nikkei perd deux et demi pour cent du
jamais vu dans l'histoire du kabuto cho
mais tokyo va être aussi la première
place à effacer et au delà les effets du
crack depuis elle a même gagné 3% se
hissant au premier rang devant new york
et londres
3 pour la première ressource y aura bien
une autre chance il compresse
molière le monde là derrière si on
constate cette année le taux de change
ne varie pas comme les autres d'amener
le toiser mancelle une liquidité du
marché japonais
son fret abandon comment je vais vous
expliquer alors que wall street ait
perdu la face presque devant tokyo le
japon est un de population qui se
soutiennent entre ses pouvoirs il y a
une tout conforme à une comment
dirais-je 1h30
entrée 30 pour soutenir et où il faut
comprendre qu'il s'agit là d'une
économie florissante au formidable
capacité de réaction qui attire bien sûr
les étrangers ils sont nombreux
aujourd'hui à les y placer leurs
capitaux pour tout comprendre sur le
krach lbo mais la crise ne manquez pas
ce soir à 22h15 le magazine de jean
claude guillebaud et daniel leconte avec
michel albert jean boissonnat et
frédéric mitterrand sur antenne 2 bien
sûr
à quinze jours des élections
législatives en israël un commando
suicide au sud-liban attaque un convoi
de l'armée israélienne
bilan 5 morts cinq blessés un attentat
qui durcit encore un climat électoral
alourdi par les affrontements dans les
territoires occupés paralysent est
aujourd'hui par une grève générale de
jérusalem charles enderlin la taxe est
déroulé en territoire libanais à
quelques mètres de la frontière
israélienne il camionnette piégée a
explosé lors du passage d'un convoi
militaire israélien plusieurs blessés
sont dans un état grave
les musulmans chiites du hezbollah
affirme que le véhicule était conduit
par un de leurs militants candidat au
suicide
le dernier attentat dans ce secteur date
il ya même le ministre des affaires
étrangères shimon peres a publié un
communiqué affirmant je cite qu'israël
sort à punir les assassins c'est pour
les travaillistes israéliens ces
événements sont de mauvais augure
ils proposent dans leur campagne
électorale de mettre en place en
cisjordanie des arrangements de sécurité
semblables à ceux qui existent à la
frontière israélo-libanaise la droite le
likoud a certainement expliquer aux
électeurs que des voitures piégées
risqueraient en cas de retrait des
territoires d'exploser à tel aviv
déjà le likoud accuse les travaillistes
de vouloir négocier avec yasser arafat
dans ce clip électoral le visage de
shimon peres apparaît sur ceux de
militants arabes israéliens partisans de
pourparlers avec l'ol paie la résistance
afghane frappe à kaboul neuf morts dont
3 soviétique et 17 blessés aujourd'hui à
l'aéroport de la capitale afghane
attaqué à la roquette en inde deux
accidents d'avion de même jour à une
heure d'intervalle
emmanuel vanier
165 morts deux catastrophes aériennes
dans la même journée en inde ce matin un
boeing 737 de ligne intérieure s'écrase
à 5 kilomètres de son aéroport de
destination 131 morts quatre survivants
l'appareil vieux de 17 ans serait
littéralement tombé comme une pierre ce
soir l'enquêté s'oriente vers une erreur
de pilotage
une heure plus tard deuxième accident
info caire est pris dans une tempête au
nord-est de l'inde
les 34 personnes à bord ont péri depuis
quelques semaines une campagne de presse
met en cause en inde l'efficacité de
certaines mesures de sécurité notamment
dans le contrôle de l'état physique des
pilotes
ces deux catastrophes aujourd'hui
pourrait conforter ces accusations
plus d'interviews radio et télévision
britannique de membres de l'ira l'armée
républicaine irlandaise c'est la
décision de madame thatcher aujourd'hui
cible principale de cette décision le
chine fun la branche politique de l'ira
qui compte pourtant plusieurs élus dont
son président gerry adams qui est député
cette décision a provoqué un tollé de la
presse et de certains partis politiques
les démocrates affirment qu'il sera
impossible de vaincre le terrorisme en
restreignant les libertés
procès exceptionnel à moscou devant les
magistrats de la cour suprême 3 à 0
ils sont accusés d'avoir assassiné cet
arménien en février dernier lors de
violents troubles en azerbaïdjan les
arméniens réclame toujours le
rattachement du karabakh à l'arménie 26
d'entre eux avaient été massacrés par
les azéris hostile à cette réunification
en raison de l'importance de ce procès
et des troubles permanents en
azerbaïdjan les autorités soviétiques
ont préféré confier le procès
directement à la cour suprême a moscou
les prix nobel de physique et de chimie
ont récompensé aujourd'hui deux équipes
de chercheurs qui travaillent sur
l'infiniment petit trois américains
spécialistes de la physique des
particules
leon lederman melvin schwarzenberg et
ont été couronnés en chimie ce sont
trois allemands de l'ouest your eyes and
offer robert huber et armes ou michel
une expédition scientifique française on
vient de l'apprendre a sauté sur une
mine
dimanche dernier en mauritanie trois
chercheurs français sont morts ainsi que
leur guide mauritanien un ancien
ministre de la république inculpé une
nouvelle fois pour crimes contre
l'humanité
maurice papon en charge du budget à
l'époque de valéry giscard d'estaing
ancien secrétaire général de la gironde
entre 1942 et 1944 a été inculpé une
troisième fois en juillet dernier par la
cour d'appel de bordeaux
pascal deschamps et dominique verdeilhan
nous rappelle la faire dans le dossier
du juge des dizaines de documents comme
celui ci signé maurice papon arrestation
organisation de convois il est accusé
d'avoir participé à la déportation de
1690 juif depuis sept ans l'homme crie
son innocence s'appuyant notamment sur
un rapport d'experts nommée par le juge
pour eux maurice papon n'a fait
qu'exécuter des ordres
il est même intervenu à plusieurs
reprises pour faire radier des juifs des
listes allemande une expertise récusé
par la partie civile
deux des trois experts étaient eux mêmes
fonctionnaires sous vichy une partie
civile qui met également en avant le gel
de maurice papon est une personne qui
s'évade du train la conduisant ce beach
sautant et ont réussi à sortir du train
on le signale ap ap hm pas pendre un
télégramme en disant il faut absolument
arrêter cette personne serein et
veuillez mon avis c'est quand ce sera
fait bien t'es pas obligé d'être aussi
pointilleux et rigoureux mais ça lui a
valu et nous en avons aussi la fin les
documents ça lui a valu d'être félicité
par les forces d'occupation par le
gouvernement de vichy faut quand même
pas oublier pape en a fait une carrière
fulgurante et grâce à chat préfectoral
vichyssoise pour sa défense maurice
papon cite également les conclusions
d'un jury d'honneur réunis à sa demande
un jury qui reconnaît son adhésion à la
résistance en janvier 43 mais qui
regrette qu'il n'était pas qu'il n'ait
pas démissionné de son poste préfectoral
maurice papon résistants là encore la
partie civile réagi d'après ce journal
d'anciens combattants son nom ne figure
pas sur la liste du réseau auquel il
affirme appartenir
il ya des milliers de gens en france qui
hantent les organisations leur distance
et qui sont des transfuges de vichy et
qui cependant ont aussi des titres de
résistance comme le pape en est on sûr
plus des médailles la juste ans
le juge bros at il à nouveau inculpé en
juillet dernier maurice papon hier à
bordeaux le magistrat se cachait
derrière le secret de l'instruction
monsieur papon en bon soir cette
troisième inculcation qui vient d'être
rendu public vous a bien été signifiée
en juillet dernier c'est exact monsieur
papon monsieur pas pour vous ne répondez
pas à cette question où vous ne
m'entendez pas
monsieur papon est ce que vous avez été
une nouvelle fois inculpé de crimes
contre l'humanité en juillet dernier par
la cour d'appel de bordeaux
alors je crois que nous avons un
problème technique que nous allons
peut-être essayer de réparer d'ici la
fin de ce journal
et j'espère que nous serons en mesure
d'entendre donc les explications de
monsieur papon sur cette troisième
inculpation pour crime contre l'humanité
une autre information encore une saisie
de drogue wavre et en région parisienne
où les douaniers les policiers ont mis
la main sur cinq tonnes de cannabis en
provenance du maroc
à quoi va ressembler le tour de france
l'an prochain les organisateurs ont
révélé aujourd'hui l'itinéraire et le
dosage des étapes
un parcours pour coureur complet nous
dit patrick chêne ça va être un tour de
france dure et équilibrée montagneux
équilibré pour hommes forts bon je crois
que c'est un grand cru et puis c'est un
tour très équilibré c'est bien qu'on
retrouve les grandes étapes et des
petites étapes pour que le tour soit
depuis le départ jusqu'à l'arrivée aussi
dynamique qui l'a été l'an dernier aussi
ivan découvrons donc ce tour ci plaide
et j'attends première impression il a
des allures de tour de la france même si
son départ sera donné le 1er juillet au
luxembourg
après un passage dans le nord une
journée de transfert en avion pour
rejoindre la bretagne le berceau du
cyclisme direction pyrénées ensuite avec
les classique aubisque tourmalet aspin
peyresourde et superbagnères pour
rejoindre les alpes
on passe par toulouse montpellier et
marseille étape marseillaise le 14
juillet 89
on ne pouvait faire mieux on retrouvera
les noms magiques de vars izoard
lautaret galibier croix de fer alpe
d'huez avant de prendre le tgv à l'isle
d'abeau à côté de lyon pour rejoindre
paris pour un superbe final contre la
montre
deux cents ans après entre versailles et
les tuileries le tour 89 c'est sûr ce
sera beau ainsi en ont décidé
jean-pierre courcol jean marie leblanc
et jean-pierre corps enzo les nouveaux
patrons du tour
le premier événement sportif annuel
mondial que l'on suivra bien sûr sur a2
oui puisque comme chaque année cette
antenne 2 qui vous fera vivre en
exclusivité les émotions du tour de
france l'an prochain
monsieur papon j'espère cette fois que
nous sommes en mesure de nous entendre
monsieur papon bonsoir vous avez bien
été inculpé donc une troisième fois pour
crimes contre l'humanité cette
inculpation vous at elle été signifiée
en juillet dernier non madame christine
ockrent voudrais vous signaler que je
continue de ne rien entendre
ah ça c'est gênant et je juge hadjez sur
la probité de cette prestation
c'est à dire il semblait apparemment que
monsieur pape on ne nous entendent pas
j'essaye une dernière fois je crois que
nous avons définitivement des problèmes
avec oui alors j'espère nous
pardonneraient cet incident monsieur
papon aussi j'espère j'espère qu'il sera
en mesure de expliqué donc de donner ses
propres explications sur 7 pour
troisième accusation pour crimes contre
l'humanité
alors espérons que la technique suivent
la tension est à son comble à new york
et les enjeux monte en ce moment chez
christie's mise aux enchères du deuxième
plus gros diamants du monde
on l'appelle le coulis nan il a la
taille d'un oeuf de poule c'est un
diamant jaune que paul nahon à caresser
du regard
françois curiel se concentrer les
commissaires priseurs l'un des plus
grands spécialistes de bijoux et c'est
lui qui aura dans 45 minutes la
redoutable responsabilité de vendre aux
enchères l'un des plus gros diamants au
monde
407 car a taillé en 67 pas cette fois 81
g aucune estimation n'a été avancée pour
son prix mais chez christie's
on pense qu'il atteindra sans doute le
record de 120 millions de francs
un seul autre diamant le surpasse la
grande étoile d'afrique du sud
serty sur le s'être impériale de la
couronne britannique
ironie de l'histoire nous sommes
exactement un an jour pour jour après le
krach de wall street
je peux vous dire qu'on l'a fait exprès
mais il y exactement un an nous avons eu
une très grande vente de bijoux
deux jours après le krach de suède à
laquelle une pierre a fait six millions
et demi de dollars aujourd'hui ça paraît
tout petit parce que quand on parle de
10 et 20 millions évidemment c'est pas
grand chose mais à l'époque c'était le
diamant le plus cher du monde jamais
vendue aux enchères
donc depuis le marché n'a été que de
balan de mieux en mieux et les prix des
diamants sont devenus très ferme
je pense sera plus achetées par une
société pour une certaine publicité que
par pour monsieur untel lâche temps pour
sa femme
so abuser il vous aurait pris dans notre
dernier journal à 23h50 avec henri
sannier rapidement maintenant les
pronostics de pierrette brès pour le
tiercé d'enghien demain le 7 le dise le
4 le 13 le 5 le 1 le 2 et le 8
voilà dans un instant laurent cabrol va
nous parler du temps merci d'avoir suivi
ce journal admirateur
e